l'italie dans l'impasse le président
serge dyot matarelle a refusé
l'investiture d'un ministre de
l'économie ouvertement europhobe proposé
par le premier ministre désigné guissepe
comté qui échoue donc amené la coalition
cinque stylet et ligue au pouvoir le
président de la république donc va
convoquer de nouvelles élections et
entre temps à nommer un premier ministre
technique
une décision qui a fait bondir les deux
leaders on écoute
nous devons amener cette crise à
l'intérieur du parlement ce qui signifie
avoir recours à l'article 90 de la
constitution sur la responsabilité du
président et c'est au sein du parlement
que nous devons en débattre
ensuite le parlement décidera mais
gardez à l'esprit que nous conjointement
avec la ligue possédons la majorité
parlementaire
ils doivent nous dire si le gouvernement
est déterminé par l'écart entre les taux
d'emprunt à bruxelles berlin et paris
nous ne nous résignons pas nous
n'abandonnons pas nous serons plus forts
et plus déterminés qu'auparavant soit
les règles européennes change soient
restés dans cette union européenne n'a
plus de sens dans notre programme
n'était pas question de sortir de l'euro
ou de l'europe
pas de bray xiti rien nous avions
seulement pour projet de changer les
règles européennes au bénéfice des
italiens selon moi le plus grave c'est
que le président de la république a
choisi les marchés des règles
européennes au détriment du vote des
italiens
et ça c'est sérieux et pour commenter
donc ce psychodrame cette presque ce
reality show à l'italienne c'est edouard
martin que j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
vous êtes député européen socialiste
bonjour bienvenue
est ce que justement on entendait à
l'instant matteo salvini le leader de la
ligue
est ce que ce n'est pas une trahison du
vote des italiens ce qui est en train de
se dérouler ce que je constate c'est la
troïka qui pointe le bout de son nez
quoi bce et commission rappelle
exactement où c'est effectivement ce
sont ces institutions si on en croit ce
qui se passe en tout cas ce message qui
est perçu par les italiens c'est le
monde de institutionnel le monde de la
finance qui doit déterminer le vote des
italiens donc non respect de la
démocratie
on peut ne pas aimer ça me fait pas
plaisir moi ce vote italien en tant que
démocrate je me dis à l'italie part sur
de nouveaux chemins ça ça risque
de tanguay y compris pour nous mais bon
je suis un démocrate je respecte la voix
du peuple italien et donc plat le
message qui est envoyé
c'est dire aux italiens vous avez mal
voté c'est nous qui allons vous
apprendre comment voter on va vous est
imposée à notre vote c'est quand même je
veux dire en terme de messages c'est
terrible les dégâts que ça peut s qu'il
faut dans ce cas là comme du coup di
maio le leader en fait des cinque terre
et le demande destituer le président
matin et là je me garderai bien de dire
ce que le site doit fermer effectivement
il faut user utiliser l'ensemble des
textes existants en italie la
constitution et matar et la refusant le
poste de premier ministre mais ce comté
parce que il aurait une politique qui
régnait au contraire des intérêts
européens
c'est terrible comme match et en plus
nommer un ministre un technicien un
ancien du fmi
je dire en termes de communication et
d'image que reçoivent les italiens en
pleine figure
on fait pas mieux pour faire exploser un
pays je veux dire c'est est ce que ces
gens là sont conscients de ce qu'ils ont
provoqué pression qu'il attendrait que
selon vous en faites à ce que ce soit
bien pire une fois que les italiens
revient droit aux urnes
moi je le crains je crains très
fortement que les italiens vexé fâché et
on peut comprendre cette colère des
italiens sanctionne encore plus durement
cette position cette posture du
président italien et fasse que salvini
soit renforcée alors il ya aussi les
sorties de la part à la fois des manuels
macron qui a salué le geste de sergio
matarelle hacker a donc reçu furent
départ du ministre donc de l'économie
qui est ouvertement europhobe guenther
oettinger qu'est le commissaire au
budget lui a fait savoir dans une
interview à la deutsch vélo donc une
radio allemande
de manière un petit peu
voilà plus nuancé tout du moins que
finalement en fait les marchés à
apprendre aux italiens comment voter
est-ce que là aussi du côté des
capitales et du côté de bruxelles en
fait on joue pas un peu au pompier
pyromane qu'on joue sur les peurs et
maliens macro qui vient de son petit
coupé de son petit commentaire je ne
sais pas comment il aurait réagi
s'il ya un pays autre aurait commenté
c'est la nomination de ses ministres je
deviens pas le pensent les autres pays
de colons que pensent les autres pays de
et douars philippe enfin bref je veux
dire ça c'est de notre compétence et
personne n'a à la commenter
il faut réformer cette europe il faut
réformer cette europe l'europe des
citoyens aujourd'hui la réponse que
l'europe la porte c'est je tourne moi en
tant qu'institution le dos aux citoyens
italiens et c'est pas comme ça qu'on
pense que